Wow blow this huge
but it's so empty where's all the
furniture and where is everybody
am I too late Wow
press the button for the bus to some of
the human with answers you are killing
me
just relax
I gotta do exactly what I'm doing hello
[Music]
it's like this place hasn't been
finished off inside hello hello where
are the guests supposed to sit I thought
you don't know I was just hanging out
sorry to catch your first night Richard
Richard but around here they kind of
call me Papa Papa Papa papa
we're just battling's all of us are in
nirvana do you normally run for this
this Baldur's to my room okay
and then when music starts coming I turn
it over music the music program women do
tonight says the music there's a bad
placement yes and then we'll probably
jam out later aren't you in the Butthead
what is the Baja just helping it would
you like to see the Butthead I'd love to
see the Baja okay yeah this is where you
run the reception from the Baja yeah Wow
this is the Baja this is where me and
Trudy hang out get up smell what is that
smell
we've got incense they're right here
incense yes a strong [ __ ] incense
yeah Jesus
yeah but that doesn't smell like the
smell just smell yet herbs it's a
medicinal herb
I love herbs especially the freshness of
it you can use it for cooking if you
want to do a really nice fettuccine okay
was it like a Bisset yeah it's like a
basil Wow it has a nice smell to it
[ __ ] me that's definitely not basil is
this cannabis yes
so we smoke pot that's why I could smell
the minute I came in here yeah would you
want me to tell is this Li you here yes
I use medicinal herb before you put your
hands back in that cookie jar what if I
save my room it's and get a bit late oh
I've done for a while okay you know how
do I get to the room I'll show you this
is a first the owner of this Lodge is as
high as a kite Wow look at this place
he probably doesn't even notice the
place has no furniture this is the
cattlemen room gentleman room thank you
yeah
it smells like cattle in here Wow why
I'm to the carpeted I'll have an
accident you know we party allowed here
so you're gonna have liquor
who knows what's all these carpets right
what's that that's just bugs a bugs
blood see how ya like crispy belly long
leg that's disgusting and this is your
view out here I didn't notice the view
because the carpet my God why stunning
location it's paradise it truly is yeah
I mean this place is stunning show me so
filthy Richard so the bedrooms up here I
was right what in the hell has happened
to this carpet I haven't been up there
in a while it's more stains on this
carpet than inside Hugh Hefner's [ __ ]
wife row yeah I told you they party in
here no but how I mean how many come
look at this couch every rooms got those
stains are me now I would rather cover
on the bed when was that from 1970 you
have talked did you earn about 10 John
that's your wife ex-wife
hey so damn yeah damn yeah she wants to
be a business what you should be this is
not a business to me
don't ask me finances because I would be
lying if I told you I knew anything I
don't let's catch up later I'm gonna get
our bags okay okay
thanks for the update this place is
disgusting and it's hardly surprising
seeing that the owner doesn't see it as
a business based on fresh air he clearly
doesn't care about paying guests
kids don't do drugs and end up like that